the reason you need to make a lot of
money is not so that you can buy
whatever you want the reason you need to
make a lot of money is so that you
cannot be bought what is the most money
you've ever made from a single video I
have YouTube videos that have probably
earned for sure 40 Grand and I bet if
recent numbers would be around $50,000
from one YouTube video have you ever put
out a video that you truly regretted
posting hi it's Mel here from the think
media team and I am getting to interview
Sean canel um we are going to be diving
into all things today money moral
conflicts and of course we're going to
be looking at the the true side of Shan
canel that you don't know um just from
watching the podcast so I've actually
had the honor of knowing sea for uh 5
years now but I always say that small
business years are like dog years it
feels much longer we've been through a
lot and so um I'm excited to be able to
interview you today Sean speaking of
that first question out the gate is how
is Shawn in front of the camera
different than just Shawn like chilling
on the couch on a Friday night that's a
good question and actually in just a
second I want to hear your answer and
give you permission to be fully
unvarnished I feel
like at least from a self-awareness
perspective that sometimes when I get on
camera I turn it on more when I get on
stage I turn it on more more energy more
humor and that sometimes probably in
person I can be pretty toned down and
super
chill now I think there's my personality
that's super chill I also think there's
a kind of a somewhat sad or challenging
part of this which
is I go so hard in my craft that I push
myself to fatigue so I can be also just
generally tired and so that's the the
results that maybe my family gets if I'm
even more nuanced about that one of the
interesting things about couples is they
say men speak about 5,000 words a day
women speak about
15,000 and a problem for couples is that
if a man goes to work from 9 to 5 he's
probably used up all of his
words and then when he gets home if his
partner spouse is like I feel like
you're not you don't have a ton of
energy or a lot of Engagement or whatnot
man he's depleted he's it's all he only
had 5,000 words and I feel like I like
communicated speak words for a living so
if we do web classes and meetings and
processing issues and all of this stuff
in a day that sometimes between 9 to 5
when I get off work there there is again
some fatigue that is set in or just a
depletion that is set in that's a whole
I don't maybe help somebody listening to
the podcast for their own marage to
think about how they could potentially
you know at least be thoughtful about
that so I am trying to think about how
can I turn it on be really present for
my wife my kids Crank It Up so that's
the that's the thing that comes to mind
I do feel like I'm the same person but
there is something about of course on
stage you're going to be different than
you
are just at a a party and social event
you're be different on video I do try to
maybe I talk constantly on camera in
person I feel like I try to listen more
and just try to and so I don't know but
I do completely I could be wrong too I
don't know what I don't know you see me
in both environments what do You observe
well I do think that you're absolutely
right that we kind of call it customer
service voice sometimes right or it's
like your camera voice of course you're
going to have more energy that's
actually your recommendation to people
we tell people that all the time so of
course there's going to be those nuances
but I think there's a definite through
line between you and your personal life
you at church you at social events and
you on camera um you are a consistent
person um absolutely we actually just
recorded a whole other um section of
this interview together and it really
does feel just like we're talking to
each other the way how you communicate
with other people the details that you
share obviously you're just very open
and transparent so all every story you
told like I never had a second of
thinking oh it wasn't quite the way it
was or oh that's a little embellished
like it's it is the same it's just like
as if we were talking um on zoom on on
an a random meeting during the day so I
think that is one thing I would want
everybody to like be able to see is a
little bit more of like Sean like chill
like fun like you also get super goofy
sometimes and I don't think people get
to see that as much it'd be nice to get
that on the podcast we'll see yeah yeah
we'll see if we can get it if you join
us on a web class one of our classes we
do that's where you get Sean a little
more and some challenges after all those
sessions one of those Q just starts
super random super Delirious I love
that's I love that environment Delirious
Sean is by far the the most fun Sean but
as far as your character and everything
that is um absolutely consistent and I
love that people are going to get to see
a little bit more of that hopefully with
these more in-depth questions um
throughout these videos so the first
question I want to get into let's just
Dive Right into money talk so um
everybody wants to like here's us
talking about our monetization
strategies in our web classes and and
videos but what is the most money you've
ever made from a single video so I want
to say it's around
$36,000 it might be higher than that but
that is how much think Media made off
what's called a Content marathon and I
did a whole training about it now where
things get really interesting is
is there is like direct monetization and
there's maybe indirect monetization
which you'd call like brand building so
what about the influence and the
subscribers and what if that led to
other things there's also the fact that
over time at think media we've built out
multiple streams of income so one video
might make X number of dollars in ad
Revenue but it also could produce X
number of dollars based on affiliate
link clicks and then it also May promote
an online course or a book which also
would generate sales and we work really
hard at think media to track thanks to
you our chief marketing officer who's a
genius and you've got an incredible team
including you and Jeffrey who does paid
advertising as well as what's called
wicked reports it's a higher end
software with crazy levels of tracking
in terms of tracking when someone
started their Journey with you
discovered you entered into your email
list when they maybe purchased something
or whatever were you using UTM codes and
all of that stuff and that's a high
level of Mastery and sophistication and
attention to detail so we can track
things however I think there's no way to
track if someone went to Amazon and
bought YouTube Secrets because they saw
it in like almost like quote unquote PL
product placement or something the book
I like to I'm very obsessed with having
Integrity in numbers and integrity in
everything in our business so I like to
identify what is trackable perhaps
that's around the
$36,000 for a video
um on ad Revenue but then there's the
other ways of tracking it the other
example is that there's a class we do
consistently that does track about
$36,000 in affiliate revenue from that
exact product skew it's a lighting kit
so I did a A Light review kind of a
tutorial of a particular light a budget
light kit for YouTube that video has
earned only $4,000 in ad Revenue but it
has earned about 36,000 in affiliate
marketing and so there's another one
that's around 40K so I think as far as
like a singular video in direct
monetization terms yes I have YouTube
videos that have probably earned for
sure 40 Grand and I bet if recent
numbers would be around $50,000 from one
YouTube video that's wild have you ever
had sticker shock of what somebody was
willing to pay you for something you did
on your channel have I ever had sticker
shock for something that somebody like
the amount of money they were willing to
pay me for like coaching yeah have you
ever felt like at somebody like they
should not be giving me this much money
for what they're asking me for well I
mean these days again I'm a small town
kid College Dropout and I mean it
sincerely when I say that as soon as I
could go to Chipotle with my wife
Sonia and get my burrito salad bowl and
get double chicken and get the stir
fried veggies and I put the hot sauce
and the P Deo on there and I get all the
way down to the end of the line and they
say would you like some guacamole and I
go absolutely I would and they go you
know it's going to be
$286 and I'm like make it two scoops
then because those avocados are healthy
but like legitimately as soon as I
became if you will price insensitive to
guacamole which make no mistake right
I'm incredibly empathetic I was born in
America definitely middle class lower
middle class for a while family is
incredibly entrepreneurial but from
maybe 6 to 14 I just remember we're
always our family was always worried
about money I remember some Christmas
gifts certain Seasons when I remember my
mom got me a peachy like a folder you
know and I was like I don't want to be
like ungrateful but as a child I like
this this is like you know school
supplies like for Christmas you know and
so just having these different money
memories and thinking about you know
growing up in in in that environment by
all means I also was incredibly blessed
always fed always lights on always roof
over my head so like there's so many
different circumstances around the world
but saying that I am very empathetic to
where you're out Sony and I got married
at 21 you're trying to have a date night
but you're just stressed about money
you're like maybe we shouldn't order an
appetizer like maybe maybe we should
split Red Robin was our play Not only
did I work there for 10 years but the
move was Red Robin California chicken
burger cut in half bottomless fries you
just took one meal come on split it two
ways people listening to this are like
oh I know those Secrets like I I you
know I know how to maximize my dollars
at a fast food restaurant or whatever so
there was no doubt about it when times
were super short so I guess growing up
that way or whatever and money being you
know from an I want to be self-aware
obviously money is important and
something that I value and something
that our family values and Something
That We're Blessed where we are now but
but I I could say in full Integrity that
it's just not at the top of my list as a
motivator so once I didn't hesitate to
order guacamole from there I feel like
I've been living
in uh house money like I feel like I
I've as soon as we reach that escape
velocity I'm like moli culen in the limo
in New York with the Giant Pizza saying
this is the height of luxury in Home
Alone like that is you know anything
that we're experiencing So my answer to
the question is these days at this exact
moment like a onh hour coaching session
with me is
$4,000 and a day is like 24,000 sign in
a discount it's like whatever eight
hours is and that's we've had multiple
people hire me either for a half day or
a day or one hour and that's still weird
it's also I think speaks to money
mindsets and beliefs that we have to
grow and evolve because now and this I I
know this I'm aware this could rub
listeners some listeners the wrong way
because it it could sound entitled I it
could sound however you want it you
think it is it could sound just as
something that sometimes we can't relate
to and by the way I'm with you I think
it's weird just as weird as you think it
is but actually where it's really
helpful is to have objective third
parties like Jordan Perez my executive
assistant guarding and protecting my
time because one of the ways I think
about the reason we charge those numbers
is a supply and demand situation is a
calculation of company revenue and how
much as the CEO I'm very aware it's a
collective effort that builds that
Topline Revenue but nevertheless if I'm
at the helm then that number is
attributed to me and so Dan Kennedy
wrote in a book on the ruthless
management of people and profits that
you should write down how much your time
is worth per hour one exercise The
Listener could do is do that and once
you wish your time was worth per hour or
stretch it so you grow into it the other
way to do it is just do the math off of
like what your company is making net
profit Factor it by 40 hours a week for
50 weeks a year some people would tell
you to cut that down because there's no
way you could be perfectly productive
for that entire time so they even say
cut that number in half say what net
profit is calculate that according to
the hour here's the bottom
line I those numbers are supply and
demand numbers to do coaching and so
yeah I still think it's incredibly weird
to get paid you know $4,000 for an hour
of my time but what I also have to learn
is that I still am tempted you hear me
oh yeah I want to I want to give free
coaching I want to you know just book
that on my calendar I'd love to help
that person I would love to give and
there's there's a lot of that we do
sometimes with churches and Ministries
ministers on YouTube and different
things where where were in a blessed
position to give free coaching or to
give Consulting in certain situations or
a discount but anyways I'm still sticker
shocked by kind of all of the above I
think that's a good thing I want to stay
humble and grounded I think there's also
a tension where I have to elevate my
thinking and my mindset and this was
maybe the point I was trying to make
because yes the money is Sony and I as
the co-founder of the company that we
can technically do whatever we want
speaking of like net profit of company
Revenue but the way I view it is it's
ultimately God's money and I I
ultimately view it as God's company and
so I try to have a stewardship
perspective
therefore we're not solving for how much
money can we take out of the company and
just try to like spend in this or that
way we're trying to solve for how do we
further the mission further the purpose
how do we grow how do we be faithful how
do we be smart like Joseph in seven
years of abundance to prepare for seven
years of famine
so I don't want to have sticker shock
maybe that's the point I want to elevate
my I want to stay humble but elevate my
mindset of my perspective to the level
of value that we're gen producing to the
marketplace because I think it's also
upward from here and that is a personal
growth conversation a mindset
development conversation a money mindset
and beliefs Evolution that I think is
super important and that's been part of
the journey that I'm on hey in just a
second we're going to get back into the
episode but if you haven't heard for a
limited time you can get on demand
access to my YouTube strategy class
entirely for free at think
masterclass.com on the class you're
going to learn the one strategy that we
use at think media that is currently
generating over 300,000 views every
single day if you are new to YouTube
this is going to help you start right
and avoid mistakes and if you're already
a pro this is going to help you multiply
your growth and the cool thing is the
class is 100% free and you can watch it
instantly on demand all you got to do is
go to to think masterclass.com or just
click the link in the show notes to get
instant access all right let's jump back
into the episode have you ever faced a
situation with a lucrative brand
opportunity or business opportunity that
conflicted with your personal uh moral
boundaries one time and this was you
know early on with coaching when my
coaching was more affordable and you
could just hire me for one one coaching
for an hour or
two I was also trying to set up
filtering systems and this is when you
don't necessarily have a lot of Staff
you know at one point now the director
of our think media channel Kyle Anderson
who's like the executive producer
producer over the entire Channel we're
in Anderson Studios right now absolute
Legend running a team of like seven
eight nine 10 people alltime creative
like we're just thinking about like this
very Studio which he designed he's an
artist he's a creative I mean he's got
vinyl records playing behind us on
breaks like you could tell he's a real
hipster so
ultimately um when he started think
media he
was our administrative customer service
representative which number one is not a
skill set but number two it's not a
skill set and also was funny because U
and I just remember too I was like bro
you got skills and I think he's working
at a a warehouse folding clothes or
something at the time I was like I don't
know what it is but you got to come and
think come to think and help us build
and again and and grateful because
that's part of the journey it like
started messy started in one area and
he's probably worn like every hat in
every Department well what's the point
the point is that our admin our systems
our filtration systems over the years
haven't been the best and for example I
remember I did coaching with this one
person who was in he was kind of like in
pickup artist and
seduction type of things kind of about
it was kind of like polygamy
it was kind of
like how do you like essentially trick
multiple women to date you and marry you
and um have control over women and sex
and all kinds of stuff so I was like
this was a dark dude and it was actually
like his assistant or something and I
mean I found myself in that moment this
one of those moments as a Christian
Christian business owner you know
thinking through things where I'm like
okay this person hired me for coaching
I'm I'm in it now they're like here
here's my channel I'm opening up the
channel and I'm like oh here we are but
I'm also I'm thinking in in hindsight's
2020 I don't know what what should I
have done canceled it been like you know
what let's refund your money in that
moment and so all I did was I followed
through on the coaching session and then
passed it along to whoever was helping
us with admin was like we need a better
filtration system because that is not
something I can endorse or get behind
there's the there's one thing about
giving giving free content away that
anybody can watch uh and I think for the
Christian I I think that
is okay I mean consider that the Bible
is freely readable by everybody and
people have manipulated or Twisted it so
it's little bit about giving good
information putting it out in the world
there's a whole another thing about
accepting
clientele that is not even a great area
but is absolutely counter to your belief
system and your values so that was one I
remember that uh I you know I wouldn't
do again and we've done our best to try
to be thoughtful and I also think one of
the reasons I heard my friend Neil
dingras say this he he tweeted on uh
threads which was a weird statement
because he actually threaded on threads
and it's not Twitter anymore and so as I
digress and he said the reason you need
to make a lot of money is not so that
you can buy whatever you want the reason
you need need to make a lot of money is
so that you cannot be
bought come on Neil and
so early on when we're fighting for
survival the Temptation could be to if
you will take whatever coaching client
or do whatever what is nice is being at
a place where you can refuse business
now I would argue for anybody at any
level you can refuse business at any
level and I and I would go you could go
like the optimistic kind of like
Charismatic Christian perspective would
say and God will bless you if you turn
down business for your integrity and
your ethics you're going to be blessed
double as a result yeah maybe or you
might just be persecuted even more and
your business could fail like I mean
ultimately but but the challenge is are
you going to stand hard and fast on your
conviction that's a big one that uh I
would um lean on and then I mean another
one to unpack which is I think is a good
moral conflict that we've talked deeply
about in our company as we've tried to
develop brand deals and a brand deals
team
that is focused on sales meaning get a
brand deal that'll pay us money because
that's how we pay the bills which is all
great and ethical because that is
business-wise important but then you
also have the Creator which we as we've
grown is Nolan and Omar and others that
have been the ones actually creating the
content but then you also have what
should supered all which would be your
values and beliefs and convictions of
what brands are you endorsing but also
would be an absolute commitment to
Integrity truth and giving the best
answers results software and tools to
the end user so so of course I might
have an opinion and I could be right or
wrong and so people can watch or follow
my opinion about a camera of
course there's many nuances in the
middle but it true Integrity I think
looks like you know being true to
yourself endorsing things you only
believe in and then serving the end user
most of all always trying to think about
what's in the audience's best interest
um and only getting behind products that
you believe for them there's been some
of the conflict we've had which I would
argue I have tried to be or I think I
have been hard and fast on this and
we've had some internal conflict we've
had some staff transitions since then
not that that was like the whole issue
but that was some of the debates that
would come up around the brand deal
table if you will is I would just be
like okay that's cool they want to give
us money but that's not software we
believe in well that's cool they want to
give us money but that's like not what
we're actually using we then started to
learn and make a scoring system where
it's one thing to do an ad read versus a
dedicated video it's one thing where are
you fully endorsing it but I think that
these kinds of things are very important
we did a couple episodes on the podcast
a while back about Bible versus every
content creator should know and and
there's the Bible is really clear about
this and I think being trustworthy
having
integrity and then one there was one big
one where at a really macro software in
the crater economy there's two big
competitors and one is has tried to work
with us and who knows maybe someday
we'll work with our ethic has always
been I've always talked to Kyle and
Nolan and Omar I've sat down and I've
said listen things can change software
could change there could be improvements
there could be updates things could
change we we need to always do our due
diligence and our research to ask what
is the best solution what is the best
software and there's no blanket answer
like that what is the best software for
beginners or the best budget software or
All Things Considered if this is the
intent we try to pride ourselves on
really getting that information I used a
recent AI software maybe I went above
and beyond maybe it's just my
personality I had to use it for like an
entire day before I could make the video
I didn't want to just shallowly describe
what it was I wanted to really get a
feel for it knowing what it is so I can
make an accurate video truly
representing it to before I promoted it
so I I think that this has been a
continuous thing that we wrestle with
but I hope that we're uh landing on the
side of uh integrity and uh and I want
to always never want to go for
short-term money over the long-term
brand and ultimately serving the end
user with as much integrity and
trustworthiness as we can have you ever
put out a video that you truly regretted
posting have I ever put out a video I
truly regretted posting this video
probably still out it's kind of funny
and it's about the human charger Evan
who us to inter for us the story like he
loves it it's he just thinks it's
hilarious because this was in the era
when there was a company called Fame bit
which was a Marketplace for brand deals
so you signed up you connected to your
channel and then it just allowed you to
scan a page lifestyle Tech electronic
pets scan a page find deals you could be
interested in and then fill it out name
Channel and it would tell you right up
front we'll pay you 300 bucks 500 bucks
$1,000 if you get accepted so you could
apply for like five or 10 of these and
maybe you'd get two or three and then
once you're approved I guess I didn't
already have the product so once you're
approved you're
in you're now the the train has left the
station like you're approved and
contractually kind of doing this brand
deal at that point so okay
so I find this thing called the human
charger I think that since then it's
gone out of business it looked like a
little iPod and it had a little circle
on it and what it did was it had two
little things that look like earbuds
like like apple you know wired in ears
but what they were was just these cables
that led up to these to the earbuds
which actually projected light into your
brain so the human charger was a device
designed to help you overcome jet lag
and because apparently your ear cavities
can see the light and and that actually
your circadian rhythms do operate by
going out they say go outside in the
morning get the sunlight in your actual
eyes not your ears um and you know so I
saw this thing and they had some like
science and some articles about it or
some whatever and I I kind of was like
all right I signed up they approved
moved me I did go on a trip because like
I said I very valued actually case
studying and field testing the product
so I went with my friend John medana to
actually we got hired on a freelance
video project in santon South Africa
flew to London flew to South Africa
brought my human charger with me I was
using it multiple times along the way
and here's the thing it it might have
been a placebo effect I I I oh I'm
open-minded you know my ears are open to
the the light you know and it might have
been a placebo effect it might have been
total pseudo
science by the way the video was still
public like I feel enough okay enough
about it and I'm already like this was
me being true to me I am a psycho
biohacker I do a lot of weird pills and
suppositories and
potions and red light therapy and all
kinds of stuff my wife fun of me for it
you are worried about my kidneys I was
like I think I'm like it's really
painful when I pee but there's like no
blood I did take like an excessive
amount of supplements yesterday and
you're like that's really hard on your
kidneys and so so I'm already like a
human charger type of a person like I
would be that guy so anyways I made a
video I described what it was I
described the articles that they had and
I described my experience I was like
this was a grueling trip and when we got
off I did it I'm landing it and that's
the thing you don't have have access to
light like that supposedly that is
vitamin D or whatever wavelength when
it's the middle of the night and you're
jet lagged so you're human charger there
for you to inject your ears with light
at any time you want so I put the video
out man the comments like the comments
are like
you this is the ultimate snake oil for
the snake oil salesman like what are you
talking about and then various debate I
mean probably some smart people would be
like there is zero scientific I mean
this product sure went through a lot it
went all the way it was an actual
product I don't know if they're still
out there who knows maybe the founders
will see this video I'm still neutral on
it but all I know is that and a
difference between making that video or
not making that video that video should
not be at like the top of the list of
like even the a 100 priority videos I
should cover I think an interesting
principle is we encourage people on
topic all the time like sure you you
could do this or that topic but are you
actually making videos about the best
topics so what are the top 10 videos I
should cover the top 20 the top 30 maybe
even the top 250 videos I should make
next human charger by the way I think
it's on think media what is that even I
mean it kind of it's like I sometimes
veered a little bit it's not a camera
it's not Tech related it was Tech uh but
it it's like for the traveling content
creator maybe you want to inject light
into your ears so I could probably
passed on that one and and it speaks to
you know early on lobin out 10 Fame bit
applications getting approved for it and
then in hindsight thinking back and
being okay let me be more selective more
thoughtful and hopefully build more
Authority and brand and the opportunity
to be selective of brand deals that's a
whole another side note is personal
opinion ethic media we help people with
brand deals we help people with patreon
we help people Channel memberships
there's so many different things but my
personal opinion I didn't just want to
create an online course because I really
believe in the methodology of of online
courses change my life
they help me learn things help me build
wealth help me build a business I
continue to invest in education products
so I believed in the product itself as
an actual user but the other reason I
wanted to create a product whether it's
an online course or something else is to
be free from situations like that that
was one of the situ just to be to be at
a place don't make so much money so you
can buy whatever you want make enough
money so you can't be bought so that
actually you can turn down brand deals
turn down coaching and by creating a
product of your own that you can sell
and creating enough margin and if you
will wealth you create enough protection
that yes then when you engage a brand
deals and I feel like that's where we
are now they are a big part of our
business we are investing a lot in them
but we want to be stable enough that
that's not the only thing we're relying
on so that ultimately we could be bought
cuz like oh my gosh if we don't get a
deal this month and there's only one
deal to choose from then we're not going
to be able to make payroll all right I
guess it's the human charger it's kind
of a gray area maybe it's really clear
to some people but like being able to
turn down different deals so that's
that's one of them It's Kind of a Funny
Story and the jury is still out we'll
see about comments on this video version
of this any scientists know can you
actually inject light into your ears to
counteract jet lag let us know in the
comments let us know need to know well
Sean I have so many more questions I'd
love to ask you um but we're going to
wrap up this interview for today if you
want to see more content like this then
make sure you like subscribe um share
this video out with people who would
also enjoy watching it and you can
actually join Sean and I um on a web
class tonight it's just a free class
that we do to teach YouTube strategy and
that's where you're going to really get
to go a lot deeper in YouTube strategy
than we get to do in um even these
videos and so we would love to see you
on that class um tonight or wherever you
are in your time zone you can just head
to the link that's in the description
right now think masterclass.com and see
us over on that class so we can hang out
and maybe we'll get Delirious Sean on
that web class and you'll get to
actually get to laugh with us as well
we'll see you over there